r r with the Lords
we have Lord King David here with Tyler
and we're going to be talking about the
movie Shazam now um I got a chance to
see Shazam and I have my little uh
comments and stuff that will go towards
that but at this moment I really want to
get Tyler's input on how he felt the
movie was and did it live up to
expectations that was set forth from WB
man so
I first off I thought the first movie
was better so easily better first movie
was really good right first movie was
awesome this one I didn't think was
terrible but I think DC has this issue
with their movies they want a movie Dark
they go way too dark on everything right
if they have a comedy it's like no
character can take anything serious ever
there's no in between and I feel like
that was kind of like my biggest nitpick
of this movie is like so you thought it
was too campy too campy too jokey no
like when things get down to seriousness
there's none of that it was still let's
try to make jokes and I get the
characters a child but but yeah I so I
liked it right I just didn't think it
was as good and I feel like it's still
high or uh Amplified DC's biggest
problems with their movies
all right well I went into this film and
I went into thinking you know that this
phone was going to be ridiculous I
thought exactly believe I was a
fantastic actor and I thought that the
the costume changes I mean because we
know that is uh Toy placements right so
the costume changes was fantastic they
went meticulously down the line you know
uh Mary Marv will look great uh you know
Shazam looks great you know Captain
Marvel look who carry Billy you know as
a character himself he looks great I
thought the makeup artist was a little
bit off The Mark with some of the older
actors that was there I thought they uh
the makeup didn't translate well to the
on screen uh I thought the plot Point
really was weak and I saw the agendas
that they were trying to push inside the
film and I'm thinking that you know yeah
you know we know that Shazam in the
cartoons and on the comic books is a
character a kid character that is
growing up and they had a lot of jokes
leaning into his name the fact that
Warner Brothers can and say the name
Captain Marvel
they had Hallmarks to the TV show where
you had the actual guy who played
Captain Marvel there on on set who said
you know let's go Captain Marvel
um I think at this point in time WB
don't know the identity and this movie
was set up to win I thought it felt
completely flat the movie was boring in
spots the action scenes uh wasn't
believable at points but again you have
a superhero movie which is based around
two villains that you didn't get the
backstory to uh until well on into the
film The main antagonist uh turns at the
end point of the movie to become a
Helper and a good guy absolutely made no
sense within the film you saw the plot
leaks during the whole film I didn't
think that the plot stood the test of
time how did you feel about the plot no
I agree it fell rushed again just Broad
View you can go and watch this movie and
enjoy it you you're not gonna hate the
whole thing 24 7. right but it was
really rushed not everything was
explained the back story was where I was
it felt like uh people were making
decisions without like you said a whole
lot of explanation to it yeah oh I have
his Crush you know so I'm just gonna
jump over with you instead of a whole
lot of
thought to it exactly it felt really
rushed and uh I won't say lazy but rust
is probably the best word I thought the
CGI was poor yeah uh again I had high
expectations for this film and I felt it
felt flat I gave it two popcorn out of a
five popcorn system uh what rating would
you give it
I feel like two two's probably accurate
yeah again I I loved the first one the
first one was hilarious it was good all
the way around you go in the second one
hoping you get the same thing and it's
not close so actually falls flat yeah it
falls flat
um you can again you can watch it and
enjoy it but it's not by any means close
to what the first one was so
I personally would not recommend you go
see this film I will wait for it to come
on any streaming device that you
actually watch any streaming service
that you actually get and uh that's a
weight on this film again this is iron
Lords podcast this is Lord King coming
to you with r r with the Lords uh Lord
addict did not see this film that's why
Lord addict is not in this set but uh
Tyler and I did so definitely check it
out
thank you
he felt like to me if Bruce Lee was
allowed to age yes yes absolutely uh so
Diana played a blind character named
Kane who was a lifelong friend of of
John Wick and I forget the other the
name of the other character uh um
Japanese character who's been he was in
the last number oh yeah and the one that
was on bullet train yes one thing I
don't like about Kane is because I feel
like at the beginning they kind of like
put him in Realms of reality where he's
putting the sensors up to make like okay
this is how he fights right but then
that's literally after that's okay now I
guess you can see everything
I liked it it felt like as soon as he
was close to something he could he could
parse it out
the stairs he hitting everyone like like
he knows
they're like they're not paying
attention to this part but I like the
fact they even gave him that words like
all right he's not superhuman he needs
all of these things to sort of figure
out where people live it's like they did
it just to show he's blind
yeah so I'll tell you this I again I
right off the bat the fact that he was
attacking the high table at the
beginning of the movie I was like yo
wait wait so he's thinking in his mind
he's like I am I'm ending this from the
top I'm cutting the snake's head off
yeah and what they told him is like my
table is kind of this omnipotent thing
you kill individuals
someone just comes to take over it the
network is that big it's like shadow of
mortal exactly there's always another
one right it's the Nemesis system he has
a nemesis system I know so it is this
thing where it's like he realizes that
it's like okay if you want to exact your
revenge if if exacting your revenge
takes you to to the path where hey I
just want to get out yeah where is my
path to getting out and when he finds
out the path to getting out it seems
like a much simpler simpler
quote-unquote path than
destroying the whole thing yeah because
you can't he accepts that he can't
destroy the horse right he just wants
out and to me what I loved about it was
the pure action and the way they
elevated the action in every single big
sort of set piece action action a moment
they they elevate the action in weird
ways that you wouldn't even that you
didn't expect it because attic and I
thought it was going to be one way with
that last step scene yes and
what's what's funny is we thought it was
one way because we're like it's too
simple they're not gonna do what we
think and they do what's simple they do
the simple thing but then they then they
iterate on it and they make it even
crazier like one of the things that was
interesting to me
when they were doing the fight scene in
the street and the cars were hitting all
every time
you know either John Wick or one of the
uh his you know the antagonist got hit
by a car and got flipped on this guy you
see them shooting people in men they
were juggling people they were guns they
were doing gun juggles and I'm like okay
this is this is what you do when you
take a look at an action scene it's like
how could I make this even more
ridiculous over the top yes and it was
it was you were seeing video game combos
in this game it was beautiful so it was
a thing I remember I forgot who told us
here but someone who told us hey they
had seen the movie already and they said
it's a video game and it absolutely is
one thing that you know I want to like
briefly talk about is like is it this
part where he's using Dragon bullets yes
it's hotline man yeah it is going from
room to room it is looking like he's
killing vampires because it's so much
fire like it it looks like blade when
blade stabs and they just blow up and
then
all right so I just want to ask y'all
which is your best if you had to pick
one fight scene
what's your best fight scene from the
show
um
I'm gonna say hmm
I'm gonna say the car scene all right I
really like that because there was a lot
of obviously that was the most
unrealistic thing to me because it's
like that's first off why is these cars
still going it's nuts
what's yours so for me one thing I
noticed is that there was less there was
less extended periods of John fighting
right and it was it was you were jumping
from seeing the scene and I love the gun
play but I love when he's able to fight
one-on-one with somebody mixing up the
gun play right with with the
hand-to-hand which is your best so the
first fight with Donnie Yen I love that
because it was both it was the gun play
all right so when it was in the glass in
the glass area yes and then after that
just one thing okay one scene only
oh that's right he fought the Kingpin in
the middle of the club I think you
really think that he's done over this
dude yeah that dude actually he can
fight because he ran away initially
right he ran away you like oh he's just
a coward surrounded by his body yeah but
no for you to sit at the table for you
all these dudes was beneath the table
right but if you have a high seat
beneath the table you have to be a
compass and do it yes and he killed uh
was it Yuri from the um the last John
Wayne who was the John with three
and they wanted to extract Revenge that
was my favorite scene now what is the
rating that you will give this being
that you're the guest host we have a
five popcorn terrified being the highest
popcorn uh one being the lowest popcorn
what popcorn it gets a five popcorn tear
for me it's for me I I get it when it
comes to they got to this point so the
story Exposition is kind of nil compared
to uh you know earlier in the series but
the action quotient is a 10. so to me
like if you you could go into this not
knowing about John Wick yeah and still
thoroughly enjoy it because it is that
kind of action movie I put it up there
with the likes of the raid yo yes they
had scenes of the radio yeah
just the right yeah exactly I put it up
there with the likes of that and that's
that's a special sort of category yeah
so to me I love it for for real that's
that was my attack
I feel like they did everything they
were meant to it's like I mentioned
earlier this movie narrative could have
been better but I think the whole point
of it was he's cleaning house he's done
with everything he's done what he was
supposed to in the previous ones and now
he's just he's bringing down the whole
house and that's why I can't hit it too
much for the narrative I do feel like
they could have done little things to
make it better I got to give it a five
give it a five I think that's the first
time I've ever gave anything a five on r
r because it was just they wanted to put
on the best action flick you could watch
and that is definitely what I watched
last night all right so me personally I
was kind of upset because there's some
characters that are there that don't
have backstory to him and I really
wanted to have backstory on the hunter I
really wanted to have a little bit more
story on a couple of other characters
you had a mid boss that I wanted the the
backstory on right but those
shortcomings
I can't deny this is probably the best
action film that's on that's on screen
uh Keanu and the team did a phenomenal
job see where he was saying that this is
the roughest like uh the roughest
physical yeah yeah of course and I can
tell I mean but I love that they mixed
it because when they did the isometric
stuff uh from room to room it felt like
a Diablo game uh top down it really felt
like a game it was like a game it was
really good very well done I got to give
this five popcorn I suggest that anybody
in the airshot of this if you're a dude
bro if you want to go there have a good
time with your friends go check out this
film uh and always keep in mind it's
like it's probably the best uh non-story
having film going but I would say the if
you were to like write them individually
The Narrative is like a three but
everything else is above a five it's
like a six and it brings that three up
two yes and hoses way so it really does
so take us out
Lord King Lord addict I had a pleasure
of watching John work with my brothers
chapter four last night with my brothers
and together together which we never
have an opportunity
left us behind us that's all right
I appreciate my Bros bringing me on onto
R yeah
I appreciate my Pros bringing me on for
RNR to discuss John Wick this is an
amazing movie go see it even if you
haven't seen the other ones trust me you
should watch the other ones but trust me
you will have a fantastic time so this
is Lord Saab signing out for r r with
the Lords from paxis 2023 Lord King Lord
attic lordsofgaming.net and the iron
Lords podcast please